hey guys welcome to the podcast
[Music]
congratulations
here we are and we are
vaccinated just so you know uh
and we are this is like a really
great um
movie like a gerard butler movie that
we're
living in right now if you're watching
this podcast
because um what it is
is we are doing this podcast because
i feel okay because i got vaccinated
um early on today
but there is a countdown here where
at any moment i could just start feeling
the effects of the vex
of the vaccination and i can break out
into a cold
sweat and get headaches
and i don't have them yet but by the end
of this episode
i may be [ __ ] so you're with me
in real time it's like that movie that
johnny depp movie nick of time
is what it is and is that movie bad yes
have i ever seen it no how do i know
it's bad
because
okay because it was called nick of time
and johnny depp was the lead and and i
guarantee you this is just something i
thought of right now i guarantee you
his his uh his name in the movie is nick
i guarantee you and that's [ __ ]
horrible
okay um i so anyway
it's called nick of time and it's and
the whole movie takes place
an hour and however many minutes and the
whole movie goes
it was like the first 24 tv show 24 but
in in the movie time
and when johnny depp was doing an
interview he was like well the really
cool thing about this
movie is that uh every every minute is
true to them to them
you know and uh anyway i left these four
water bottles to let you know
your boy's hydrating uh and he's doing
it because
supposedly that makes it so the vaccine
doesn't
uh affect you and now that i'm saying it
out loud i actually realized that that
is absolute horseshit
but um i am drinking a lot of water i've
drank and i've drank and i've drunk and
i've drawn
i never knew that test the the tents
of that and i never will and i'm only 41
so i could still learn it but
uh i'm drinking water anyway and i drank
and i've drank and i've drank
a lot of water so i drank a lot of water
i think that's what it is
and um so yeah
uh so who knows when i'm gonna get
[ __ ] cold shivers maybe i won't
and that'll be fine but yeah dude we're
doing it we're doing a podcast
uh and uh that's cool man that's pretty
[ __ ] cool dude
um i don't know where we should start
uh but we can start with um
i got my yeah i got my second vacation i
already did that so i got my second
vaccine
and my arm hurts and i i didn't work out
i was gonna i was gonna [ __ ] race
home and work out
and [ __ ] do it and uh i didn't and i
didn't do that
and tmz tried to come up to me today and
say hey chris what do you think what do
you think and i go like this you think
i'm going to talk to you
guys in my car and
[Music]
dude um yeah man and i did it
and i did it
you know what dude when i really think
about it um
i want to i want to uh say
something and uh i want to make sure
that i'm not offending this person
because i secretly think he's great
but i'm not telling you guys that
but the actor who plays sawyer on lost
should have his hair short always and
that's it
and that's it dude and that's it he
should have his hair
short always and he is a guy who should
never have long hair
and that's it dude no i don't make the
rules i'm the vessel
for the rules to swoop on through me
and they shoot out my mouth and they
tell you guys like a preacher does with
jesus but
i am not religious and i am not a
preacher
but these rules these rules that come
into my they honestly i think they enter
through my anus and they come
in and they move through my intestines
and they come up through my esophagus
and they fire out to let you guys know
the guy who played sawyer and lost
should have short hair always
because he looks much better in that
[ __ ] new show whatever he's doing
with the girl from uh
walking dead i don't ever know a show's
name i only know
the actors in it were in something else
that's how it is from now on i think
that's what being in your 40s is like
yeah it's the show with the girl from
walking dead
you mean colony i don't know
it's to show with the guy from lost we
used to have the long hair
colony i don't [ __ ] know so he should
have short hair and that's that and i
figured that out and that's all good
and um so you're welcome for that
and uh i'm always here for the
hard-hitting issues
josh holloway that's what it is ah yes
dude josh holloway
is uh he's cool dude i bet that guy's
nice as [ __ ] i bet he's nice as [ __ ]
he i never heard one story about that
guy but i bet he's one of those guys
one of those actors where people have
stories and they're like dude you know
josh
uh holloway gave um uh
who would it be giovanni rabisi when he
was
uh coming up josh holloway gave giovanni
robisi
his shoes and josh holloway walked home
uh and it was like three miles
or something like that because joshua
holloway walks a lot
speaking of which dude have i ever
talked about this who's that guy thomas
jane
that's yeah i know i've talked about him
i saw him once on an event with [ __ ]
no shoes or socks on
oh gonna [ __ ] step on a syringe dude
he
got out confident and as all get out
which was i like that but also wear
shoes and socks
because they're cities now you know what
i mean wear shoes and socks
because they're cities now and it's not
like we all live [ __ ]
in tribes here in la but he um
he did that and in a way he was my hero
and my enemy at the same time because
i'm jealous of a guy who does that but
also hey guy wear shoes and socks
um one time i got out of jujitsu
when i was [ __ ] i was must have been
yeah and i got out of jiu jitsu and i
didn't have my shoes on and i walked to
my
dude this is how [ __ ] crazy i am i
walked to my car
as i was working in my car i stepped on
something and
it stung me and i was like oh [ __ ] but i
kept walking
i kept walking got in the car drove all
the way
from wilshire boulevard to burbank now
for those of you that don't live in la
[ __ ] you you don't get to know how long
that is
all right it's 40 35 minutes
i'll tell you and so um
i got back to burbank and i hung out for
a little bit and then i started thinking
about
how i hurt my foot and i was like
wait a second i just assumed that it was
a bee
but what if it was a syringe and i
thought
nah it's not because i would have known
i would have stepped on the whole needle
it would have been fine whatever
let the [ __ ] thought get buried for a
little bit then
my ocd goes like this
[Music]
and i'm like
who is it and they're like it's your ocd
i'm sleeping i'm just going to go back
to bed and my ocd's like
all right and i'm like okay
and then my ocd
oh my god damn it
give [ __ ] just see what the [ __ ] they
want
walk over
hey hey yeah it's me again no i know
what's up
hey um you know how you said you thought
that uh maybe it was uh
it wasn't a syringe it was a syringe but
then you realized it probably wasn't
because you would have felt the whole
mechanism and yeah i remember
yeah well what if um just the needle
came off
and it was on the ground and the
mechanism wasn't attached to it
um you can still get
tuberculosis that way anyway we just
wanted to drop by and
throw that thought up in your [ __ ]
bitch-ass head
but but go to bed go go back to bed
okay i guess i'll drive back
my ocd left the door open because they
knew i was gonna [ __ ] drive back so i
[ __ ] drove
back from burbank to [ __ ] wilshire
boulevard another 35 minutes
drove all the way back dude got out of
the car and when i got out of the car i
thought what the [ __ ] am i even looking
for a dead
bee i don't even know where i stepped
really i just walked you're not thinking
about where you're stepping
so i'm [ __ ] tracing my moves
back all clean because i already
showered from after jiu jitsu i looked
like i was
i looked like i was ready for it i
looked like a guy that was [ __ ]
looking for an ant sized date he lost
just what the [ __ ] and i'm looking on
the ground like an
[ __ ] dude like my date was honey i
shrunk the kids
and i'm just looking and i look and i
look i'm like i'm never gonna find this
[ __ ] and
sure enough dude i [ __ ] you not
i look and there is a
bee belly up dude
there is a bee belly up
outside of jean of john machado's
[ __ ] wilshire boulevard old
[ __ ] dojo or whatever the [ __ ]
and i found it and my oc
and i and when i get i drive all the way
back home happy as [ __ ]
and i get back into my apartment and i
get go to bed
and i [ __ ] my ocd i i checking with
my ocd and my ocd is like
hey i'm just here to help
and then my ocd put its hat on and
[ __ ] drove away
man i drove all the way back to make
sure it wasn't a syringe
when i knew it wasn't a syringe but my
ocd didn't know it wasn't a syringe
god ocd is sucks
it's part of the reason i'm so [ __ ] up
um so anyway dude
i i can't believe a snapple bottle
remember when the [ __ ] bitch-ass
uh commercial was in snapple and the guy
would be like
it's all mine that really buff guy at
the end it's all mine he'd say
and you'd he'd be holding the snapple
and he'd say it's all mine and
and and they and it was like why did
they cast that [ __ ] guy with no nuts
it's all mine wow i wonder if i could
find that
i bet i could actually i'm gonna look
for it if we don't if i can't find it
i'm gonna cut i'm gonna i'm gonna cut
this part out but here we go i'm gonna
go to youtube
youtube snapple it's all mine that's
what i'm gonna [ __ ] man the internet
is amazing huh
uh when it's on your side um snapple
it's all
all mine here we go snapple it's all
mine
commercial i gotta write commercial
here we go snapple it's all mine
commercial [ __ ] got it
all right cool we got it we got it guys
[ __ ]
ivan get rid of found it
oh this is it dude wow i was a year off
it's 1994.
this is it nobody's going to think this
is funny but me bodybuilder from
california rice
nothing tastes better than a snapple
after an intense workout
teddy you lift it you keep it
no doubt this guy's dead by now for real
this is a guy who would be dead now
i love how he doesn't say [ __ ] and lifts
it up
made from the best stuff on earth it's
all mine oh
he was right [ __ ] 22 years later
he remembered correctly dude
he remembered correctly
oh and he's got the [ __ ] tank top
that is so
thin it's like dental floss and it
exposes his nipples
oh he [ __ ] knows dude he [ __ ]
stays knowing he thought he had a bad
memory but he doesn't want to come says
number
[ __ ] uh commercials away in 1994
about bodybuilders because i love it
there's one thing i love
dude it's dudes bodies and that's for
real
and also their hair this guy should have
short hair as well he's got long hair in
his
dude who has worse hair honestly
than than bodybuilders for real
it's either too short and it bounces up
and down when they walk
like this like [ __ ] or it's way their
hairline is way far back and it's long
hair
those are the only two [ __ ] ways
bodybuilders have
[ __ ] hair dude oh
wow it's all mine oh my god
that is so this commercial a body
builder from california hi there a
bodybuilder dude
commercial this commercial is the [ __ ]
commercials i'll tell you what dude
all commercials suck they can never make
good commercials except when you look at
commercials 25 years ago then all of a
sudden they're good
and i [ __ ] speak the truth on that
man look at any commercial you ever
can see right now that's playing
currently guess what it sucks
hey commercials be way funnier be way
better be way more gripping
don't be too emotional if you're [ __ ]
budweiser
cool it with the horses we don't give a
[ __ ]
oh really you're not curing cancer
[ __ ] deodorant commercials chill
chill nobody puts on their [ __ ]
deodorant like this
dude they always have a guy going from
his elbow all the way down to his
[ __ ] midsection
hey dude your armpits right here your
armpits here dude
you put the stick in there and you go
like this you do a little bit
of that you don't [ __ ] all the way
why are there [ __ ] fighter j j
fighter jets
on in like deodorant commercials
for real there are gillette did that
gillette
the best a man can get it's all mine
that's how every commercial should end
wow i want to watch it again
so he does because he does what he wants
better than a snapple after an intense
workout
teddy you lift it you keep it guarantee
he's dead i'm gonna look it up after
this
you do not look like that in 1994 and be
alive
in 2021 it just doesn't happen
i don't make the rules i'm the vessel
[Music]
[Applause]
wow so unhealthy to lift it like that
it's all mine oh dude you know they
tried to get so many takes and they were
like do you
never mind it's all mine
i'ma look them up teddy on the snap
snapple teddy
snapple commercial
um age
nothing even close to came up okay
it's fine nothing even close to came up
and it's all good i sometimes i google
the wrong things um
sometimes i go go the wrong things and
that's not my fault i just try to do
what i do
and that's it uh
[Music]
but this kid this is a joke right come
on
she just sent me a a a a sister video to
this um
hold on a second hold on a second why
why is this turned off
the opposite the opposite way oh
oh i guess it's not showing that okay um
here we go
four i have produced three full-length
bodybuilding documentaries
and a half dozen contest videos i'm mike
posanella
and during that test to win dawn by the
crowd 1 30
she wants me to see this oh what is this
steve clearly had no concept of the
prerequisites of a bodybuilding contest
come on this isn't real
shaved had no tan and frankly no muscles
look the way he's doing i began to
realize that steve may not be completely
in touch with reality
is this [ __ ] actually the secret is
i'm a leader not a follower
oh this is real dude
you know immediately when someone is
serious and immediately when they're
[ __ ] wrong
when they're when they're not when
they're making a joke and you can tell
number one that this guy's serious
because
of the way he's talking number two he's
in an adidas track suit and those guys
never joke
i am telling you right now there has
never been a [ __ ] guy in an adidas
track shoot
that has been joking think about it
think about all the persons and all the
armenians that dress in the adidas
tractors
when are they joking dude
when are they joking
they're serious all the time dude
persians armenians are serious
all the [ __ ] time dude you ever see
them get out of a car
are they joking then no they're just
like what i got out of this car
i don't where's the [ __ ] place
i don't make the rules
impress me now they have those eyes you
know what i mean we're just like
what what what
unless it's like after 11 p.m and then
they really get [ __ ]
lit dude they're just like but before 11
p.m they're just like
hey hey don't hey don't [ __ ] around
don't touch a don't touch my face i
don't like when people
touch my face even when we're joking
around
but after 11 they'll be like hey how
about how he got all [ __ ] paranoid
when i touched his face oh it's a little
mexican whatever do it
hey for serious how come when i how come
when i touched his face he got like a
[ __ ] and then everyone's like
eat all your food or you'll have an ugly
wife you know they'll make up some
[ __ ] [ __ ] like that
armenians and persians they they make up
sayings that don't actually
they'll just be like hey hey remember
eat all your food or you'll have an
ugly wife
dude so this guy's doing that and that
so the reason why you know he's serious
is cause first of all he's talking and
it's serious and it's very obvious and
second of all he's in an adidas track
suit and
third of all his name is mike
pulcinella mike personella
and no one can really tell you what's
going to accept yourself
and no one knows your diet and your
training routine better than yourself
because i tried clearing my body and
also
that if i train more now time of the day
i'm over training
that point i'm hurting myself and i'm
burning myself out
but you understand one thing what's
really going on in the sport itself
bodybuilding not bodybuilding
bodybuilders are the scientific itself
bodybuilding is this
what this guy what
one thing was really going on in the
sport itself bodybuilding not
bodybuilding
bodybuilders is the scientific itself
bodybuilding is a science in itself okay
it's a whole big thing a testosterone oh
no dude that's it
when somebody says it's a whole big
thing
you know they're selling snake oil like
you
know it's a whole big thing they don't
you know they don't know what the
[ __ ] they're talking about uh it's all
big
the thing i i guess i see where i
confuse you it's a whole big thing
i'm out dude i'm already out
it's a whole big thing this is
distracting the [ __ ] out of me
sorry it's distracting this [ __ ] out of
me it's just showing you that it's like
flipping around and [ __ ]
so everything's all [ __ ] up dude
how about that when i do it how about
that when i do it i'm going to do a
bodybuilding i
if dude if i entered a bodybuilder i
used to do that when i was a kid
i would go into my parents house and a
house like i slept outside i slept in a
tree house no i would go to my parents
bedroom and i would do
i would do posing for them like i was a
bodybuilder so lanky and i will wait for
my parents to laugh
and then i will go to bed i try to win
them over
um so what's this guy talking about
throughout the day steve recited this
same speech to anyone
good stunned enough to listen good good
good
good that's good i don't like shopping
my body either way
i think that's when the work you do in
the sport you're not shocking your body
i think it's so dangerous i love this
it's very dangerous
it is dangerous bodybuilding is
dangerous and he's like the diet's
dangerous
and i agree with this guy and this guy
has the best body i've ever seen because
of that because of his attitude not
because of his body
he has the best buddy i've ever seen
because of his attitude and i love that
[ __ ] that is amazing uh okay cool good
well we figured that out this guy's my
favorite bodybuilder um
[Music]
that that was what i wanted to say about
bodybuilding what was i even [ __ ]
talking about the other thing
dude how funny are
like wait let me turn off this [ __ ] how
funny are like guys
you know what i'm talking about like i
don't mean they mean to be funny
i mean how funny are guys when they're
just together
and they're just they don't know they're
being funny and they're just
[ __ ] talking and you're like guys
shut the [ __ ] up
you know what i'm talking about dude
guys are [ __ ] hilarious when they get
together
it's like when girls get together you're
like i don't know what you're talking
about but when guys get together you're
like oh
you guys are just getting [ __ ] dumber
like
one guy is not dumb guys
are dumb the more guys together
the more dumb they are
you get two guys together you're like uh
we got to split them up so they don't
make dumb decisions
you know what i'm talking about you know
you know you know when you're like
you're in high school and your mom's
like
we don't you shouldn't be hanging out
with those boys it's cause together
you're guys and you're gonna do dumb
[ __ ]
like [ __ ] put shaving cream on a cop
car
or [ __ ] in the woods or join a
bodybuilding
competition when you don't have a good
body
that's why sports they're so
[ __ ] dumb not sports the sports are
not dumb
the guys in sports are dumb
do you know what i'm talking about you
don't need to be smart
to play football if you are it's good
for the game
and it's good and you might be better
but that's why you're [ __ ] the the
stereotype is the idiot jock
because like oh cause you're just
jumping real far
and i don't say this because i got
picked [ __ ]
fourth to last when we would do kickball
in new jersey
you know that [ __ ] guy that guy with
the cup
that meme whatever
that's me because maybe i was maybe i
didn't saying it like that guy
but dude here's the
here's the best this is what i love when
the manager gets thrown out of [ __ ]
baseball
best baseball whatever i'm just going to
play it i haven't seen this yet
but i love when managers get kicked out
dude
somebody sent me this on my patreon what
the [ __ ] is going on
there we go he's hot dude
hey get your hands off is there a more
baseball noise
than that [ __ ] in the back
wow that's amazing dude listen to this
hey get your hands off oh that's so
baseball you know the guy who said it
has a mustache period that's it
and he's got a mouth full of [ __ ]
either either
tobacco or if he [ __ ]
the doctor told him to stop doing that
because they found a polyp sunflower
seeds in his mouth
he never even [ __ ] said anything look
first
why are they micked dude why are they
miked
what the [ __ ] are they doing miking
baseball managers
and umpires [ __ ] work
on your [ __ ] shoulder [ __ ]
[ __ ] no
god damn it you've had a horse [ __ ] zone
all day also not
a [ __ ] major league baseball game
don't get that mad you don't have
much riding on it
hey you're not the brewers you're the
[ __ ]
horn you know horn hornets or some [ __ ]
you know that's not a
you're the [ __ ] golden grizzlies or
some [ __ ]
what'd he say to you what'd he say he
never even looked at you
he never even
of course his name is wally
is there a more baseball name than wally
oh this is [ __ ] wally backman
wow i know a lot of 80s and 90s baseball
players
and i was going to say of course his
name is wally like wally backman
and this is wally backman dude wally
bachman is the most baseballiest
baseball guy
of all time tied with wade boggs
wally bachmann wade boggs
and ken camanetti the three most
baseballiest baseball guys with the
baseball names
that you can [ __ ] look like look look
at them all look at what
look at wade boggs wally bachman and
look at ken cameneti
they're basically all the same guy and
if you add them all up
they equal keith hernandez that's all
i'm saying dude
they're the most baseballiest baseball
guys
and he's dirtying up the home plate no
this a child
because that means the ump have to
[ __ ] undo it and clean it
[ __ ] i never said a goddamn word to
the guy you know it yeah
you know it oh gas lighting love it i do
it
you know it and you know it and you know
it well here's something that you know
that's a great way to start a a [ __ ]
a point in an argument
or here's something that you know i
didn't do that
yeah dude gaslight city
[ __ ] yeah dude i could be a good
baseball manager because gaslight city
dude
with a gaslight city with a gaslight
city golden grizzlies here to play and
he
here we go wally bachman always getting
a little pissed off i never said a
goddamn word to the guy
you know it and that's where they get
their name folks
no this is [ __ ] i never said a
goddamn word to the guy
you know it yep yeah and the guy just
goes like this
you're right i i do know it what did you
think it was gonna be like a [ __ ]
jedi move
i love that [ __ ] dude you know it when
you point at somebody you really get
your
point across no pun intended i didn't
mean it like that know what let's go
okay
all right let's go wait hold on
i love [ __ ] like this and i will tell
you why
because how long can you be this mad
that's that's
the best part to me because
already he's been mad this mad at this
level for a minute
that is really hard
okay like it's a difficult thing to do
like it's like
fighting have you ever gotten to a fight
or like trained hard
in a in a boxing situation or a jujitsu
or a judo or a grappling kind of
situation
fighting for a minute is like
it's honestly it's like fighting for an
hour
it's just it's just hard the whole time
20 seconds after 20 seconds of fighting
you're just like
should i give up and die do you know
what i mean
so if you're arguing this long
there's the point in the argument or in
the
arguing that you know
you can't sustain it you're at the top
level of heat and you know you can't
sustain it
but especially if you're a man
or if you're a woman that had a horrible
childhood
you know you can't let up because your
ego kicks in
because if you show you're not that
angry the whole time
then you were never really that angry
right
yes and you know it
so here is the mark where i notice
wally backman is kind of understanding
okay i hit hot heat
for a minute how do i sustain this
so like any good fighter he takes a
breather
he has his hands on his hips now and
he's just kind of chilling
i can't wait to see what he says because
i know it's going to be a little bit
different
i don't know let's go i want to know
what i said
oh dude he's
right he's right about so
much in this episode of the podcast
it's like he's [ __ ] ringo starr dude
you know what i just want to i just want
to ask dude one time
i was cooking something in a microwave
when i was in high school
and i opened up the microwave
to get the food and i it wasn't hot
enough
so i closed the microwave door and my
brother
all of a sudden was right here
i opened the microwave door my brother
wasn't there and in the time i touched
the food to see if it was hot enough
decided it wasn't hot enough and needed
to put it in for another 30 seconds
and close that microwave door my brother
like the [ __ ] roadrunner
now i didn't look at him because you
know why
because [ __ ] my brother you understand
when you're in high school
and your younger brother walks into the
room
you only look at him if you're a [ __ ]
but i was the man so i didn't look at
him
my brother sensed this and he obviously
wanted to say something to me
so he said hey chris and i swallowed my
pride
and i turned and looked at my brother
and that was when i realized
his hand was like this and when i turned
my nose hit his [ __ ] pointed finger
now there's two things i want to tell
you about this
number one that's [ __ ] annoying that
he got me
and number two it hurt
way more than you could imagine
my brother knew this because he saw the
look on my face
and i was very angry so my brother
ran really fast away from me
i ran after him
he got through the front door and i
slipped and i fell on the ground
and i really [ __ ] hurt myself
so not only did i have a [ __ ] up nose
from the point from the pink finger
pink finger pointing i also
hurt the side of my hip because i fell
on the ground all right
now that made me mach 11 mad
congratulations nice to meet you mach11
mad well come on in we'll just be
hanging out for a little bit
where would you like to hang out on my
side and my nose sounds great
i couldn't catch my brother because i
had fell down
and my brother slowed down and just kind
of looked over and he goes
now i'm mock 12 mad because he's
laughing at my pain
that he caused and that he caused
so i realized i can't catch him i'm in
pain
he got a good lead start now really good
restart so i go like this
hey man come here i just want to talk to
you and i thought that was gonna work
but when he walked over to me i was
gonna beat the [ __ ] out of him
and he didn't walk over to me but my
point is you gotta switch when you're
mad sometimes
because you can't sustain the harder you
are mad
the quicker the fall is right
the sooner you want to tap out so that's
where this dude is at this moment right
here he didn't get finger pointed and
fall down but he's that mad
you know it and now he just switches
gears
i want to know what i said i'm going to
ask him what i said wow
wow because he knows what he said
because he's him
but he wants the other guy excuse me
what i said
in your report take your report and
shove it up your [ __ ]
see dude he didn't actually want to know
what he thought he said
a man dude guys hanging out together
on unreal dude you could take your
report you can shove it up your ass
i ask him what i said i'm going to ask
him what i said
in your report take your report and
shove it up your [ __ ] ass
that's some [ __ ] you know the last
guy i bumped i had to knock you on your
[ __ ] ass wow he's getting
your [ __ ] report you little [ __ ]
pimp squeak
wow [ __ ] joke wally yes god
damn it yes let's go let's go i want to
know what i said i'm i'll leave the
field when he tells me what he threw me
out
unbelievable dude i don't have to go yes
and you got to go now
what did i say guys jesus you're
goddamnit being an embarrassment to
professional baseball you're goddamnit
not being an embarrassment to a
professional baseball
like that it is right wally please let's
go
first [ __ ] time you've ever [ __ ]
umpired in professional baseball
the most ultimate slam i ever heard in
my [ __ ]
life dude wow wally's good with the slam
he's right wally please let's go first
[ __ ] time you've ever
[ __ ] umpired in professional baseball
oh
[ __ ] time you've ever [ __ ] umpired
in professional baseball
am i right no no wally let's go please
[ __ ] joke am i right the guy just
goes wally wally no
please let's go love how he keeps his
cool
love when you guys get mad dude it's
[ __ ]
hilarious he was mad for too long by the
way i'm not even gonna i don't even know
we're gonna play it anymore
this is [ __ ] minute 248 of the video
the video is
556. how how long does this go
i'm gonna just skip ahead here oh he
throws [ __ ]
oh he gets to the point where he throws
[ __ ] oh sorry guys this video is going
to be way too long
stevie will go to second oh the guy's
all about business dude
the other second manager comes in so
steve will go to second
big mistake dude big mistake you're
you're you're usurping his power and you
got to let him run hot for a little bit
so here's what we're going to do we're
going to dude and he just got done
telling another guy it was the first
time he ever coached [ __ ] major
baseball stevie will go to left
stevie will go to short move johnny hold
on a second this is him
his voice changed he was so mad and then
all of a sudden it's all mine
oh my god dude he went to he is so mad
that he
shut down and went all about his
business i love it dude
i love this [ __ ]
[Music]
he's not done being mad
that's a [ __ ] joke
through the bats oh my god this is my
favorite person in the world
through the bats through his own team's
bats out
it does nothing you just pick up the
bats after that
he threw the bat he threw the last bat
there weren't he thrown three three more
bats he's throwing three
more bats now and now he's throwing
three every time it's three back
[ __ ] up you dumb [ __ ] nice wow
oh my god can't get the balls out of the
can and then says and then struggles
with it and says give me the goddamn
ball that's like talking to jesus christ
who's he talking to the ball gods give
me the goddamn balls
i've earned this with my anger
pick that [ __ ] up you dumb [ __ ]
nice dude
me to calvin when he's when his toys are
out
threw his balls out get that [ __ ] up you
piece of [ __ ]
me talking to no i would never say that
to you no
one more get out of the way oh he
[ __ ] tells the catcher to get out of
the way
to throw the bats out
this guy's so mad you know what he is a
villain
he's a villain dude catcher get out of
the way
catch her get out of the way and just
tosses him get out of the way
uh oh just throw him somewhere else dude
two more bats
two more bats why do they have this many
bats by the way
two more bats one more and two and
another one there we go
just so many bats oh jesus two more bats
here we go one more bat here we go
another bat there we go
two more bats still kind of losing steam
here but he's doing it still
let's go have a beer doc
i got so chilly immediately
dude let's call the beer duck
of course somebody's name is doc in the
dugout dude this is the most baseball
thing that's ever happened
this is more baseball than george brett
when he's like shut my pants last night
yep don't paper [ __ ]
let's go have a beer doc
so out of breath so out of breath
god damn it i mean his wife divorced him
a week before this no doubt
oh and then some guy just whose spot is
a butler in we need to
because the game's still well he's in
dark spot he's getting for doc
so oh my god dude this is unreal
the cameraman's just zooming in on the
bats and the balls
i mean they're zooming in on the bats
and balls like they're [ __ ] people
that got left behind from the titanic
like who we don't
give a [ __ ] oh wow where's doc
oh boy gonna blame something on doc
god damn tore my nail off
some guy just told him his mic's on hey
or put mike on hey
no players are picking that [ __ ] up i'll
tell you that right now wow
still the manager even though he's off
the field telling his
players not to
how mad can you be
go get me a pair of fingernail clippers
in there
she's got some in there this guy won't
see me i'll just walk up this way
go grab him for him would you i mean
dude it's so funny that he's still
dealing with it and where he's still
mike i
i want the mic to be on him the rest of
the day and have him to go home to his
[ __ ] wife
while she's packing up because she
divorced him a week earlier obviously
that's why he's so pissed
and he's just like yo they threw me out
what's wrong with your fingernail i i
had to cut it off
wally you're leaving me huh
um dude wow
that was [ __ ] hysterical we're just
all trying to [ __ ] get by
and live you know what i mean we're all
trying to [ __ ] get by and live and do
our [ __ ] look at the way [ __ ] i cut
my i got my own hair still it's good
dude
it's good just so everybody knows
is it bad i can't see i try to do it
quick can't see it whatever dude
comic the hedgehog um
so yeah dude what i do know is my
[ __ ] if i'm watching a tv show
with my mom especially and then also
christians there
it's the most [ __ ] annoying thing in
the world dude
let me watch my show and watch it with
me
let's all do it together and have a good
time everyone
put their phones down and just [ __ ]
my mom will [ __ ] i'll be watching
lost
and she'll be like i'll i'll be hearing
like a voice
and i'll look over and she's got her
phone like this
and she's watching a video of like an
ellen clip
but it's not and then i look at it and
it's
and this is the weirdest part the
[ __ ] it's it's on
it's a facebook video like she's not
even watching like
youtube or instagram she's on [ __ ]
facebook
who watches ellen clips on facebook dude
imagine watching a facebook ellen clip
it's so annoying i'm trying to watch and
sawyer's there and i'm like why's he got
long hair
and she's ju and my next guest is and
i'm and i'm like mom what the [ __ ] are
you i have a video of it
what do you even watch why
she's listening to [ __ ] allen on her
phone
can you hear it all right [ __ ] cares
even
god who cares she is so [ __ ]
hilarious
kristen will just be on tick-tock and my
mom's watching
ellen [ __ ] clips on facebook and i'm
trying to [ __ ]
what's the [ __ ] ding what's the
[ __ ] lost song
ding ding ding ding ding
[Music]
dude i'm losing my mind we're all here
for it dude how about when the [ __ ]
when you watch it on hulu and it's like
what the [ __ ] abc that [ __ ] chime
wha whoa
what the [ __ ] is it
dude abc chime it's so heroic and it's
just
a channel whoa
and then it's just like previously
unlocked
hey channel be a channel not the
olympics
hey channel be a channel not a [ __ ]
hugh jackman movie where he [ __ ] is a
pilot or some [ __ ]
previously on lost
dude abc has some [ __ ] it'll even be
for the [ __ ] [ __ ] shows on amc
on abc that aren't like [ __ ] that's
the jingle for all the shits when you
play it
put on any song [ __ ] it'll be
[Music]
previously on [ __ ] home improvement
he's like
what whether that was nbc i don't know
who gives a [ __ ]
they're all the same nbc abc [ __ ]
naacp
[ __ ] yeah dude they should make a real
song of that just [ __ ] oh wow
wow wow whoa and it's [ __ ] counter
reeves old band dog town or whatever
that was called
[Laughter]
oh yeah [ __ ] jeremy renner should
sing it
[ __ ] yeah dude wow
god that's the same jingle if you think
about it all music's the same
[Applause]
dude all music's the same and it also
[ __ ] um
every song like 99 song percent of songs
are about love so
make a song about a hat or i'm not
listening um
god i need a [ __ ] show on fox
like [ __ ] fox news not even fox just
fox news i need to be on after
[ __ ] that guy with the bow tie that's
like well i actually blocked flap
that guy what the [ __ ] his name again
tucker carlson
that guy absolutely actually you know
dude we found the [ __ ] abc jingle
dude we found the [ __ ] abc jacob dude
this is the [ __ ] that kicks me out dude
i don't give a [ __ ] about npr man people
want to talk about the hard hitting
issues
these are the hard hitting issues dude
sawyer should have [ __ ] short hair
and the most baseball name is wally and
the fact that dude
this is the abc intro is [ __ ]
utterly [ __ ] spanking hilarious dude
previously
[Laughter]
dude how is this the [ __ ] jingle for
a [ __ ] channel dude
it's like [ __ ] imagine dragons saying
it dude
or whatever the [ __ ] that band is oh
[ __ ] dude i love
that it's this i also love that on
youtube i found it and
just it's some guy that uploaded just
named jace pearly
like why why bro what is your life like
i gotta play it again previously on
designated survival
previously on man of the house
i love to play more
[Music]
wow dude it can't like
every list of abc shows
[ __ ] yeah this is the kind of [ __ ] that
i do
oh dad that was [ __ ] loud as [ __ ]
here we go ready
previously on big sky
[Music]
previously on station 19.
previously on [ __ ] late night with
[ __ ] whatever the
white guy is ah [ __ ] man what's that guy
steve colbert isn't that on abc who
knows
who knows
previously on triage look i'm just
looking up names of shows
they're all [ __ ] like fake shows but
they're real
previously on adopted these are real
shows dude
[Music]
previously on fall and rise the story of
9 11.
god damn dude
that wasn't this [ __ ] fruit worthy
fruitful as i thought fruit worthy
wow what are all these shows dude look
at these shows
the names of these [ __ ] goddamn shows
just look i'm gonna just so there's a
here's a show on abc in 1980
it's called stone if that's not about
a [ __ ] cop named stone or a private
detective named stone
i'll cut my balls off now here i go i'm
going to click on it
stone stone is an american police drama
that aired on abc on monday nights from
january 14. there we go dude hey tv
you suck
um now you're good dude watch watch all
this stuff it's great honestly
stone
unbelievable dude that's so
funny have a goddamn jingle have a
regular jingle dude
like like the nbc nbc one is is good
right nbc jingle
here we go isn't it just the [ __ ]
simple thing
there you go that's a [ __ ] tv station
abc what the [ __ ] are you
who do you think you are nbc kills it
with that [ __ ]
three notes boom bang bong abc with the
[ __ ]
billy setzer orchestra or whatever the
[ __ ] that band is called
never knew it never knew it they got the
big bad voodoo daddy's
[Laughter]
it's like dude
they might uh for [ __ ] sake who cares
um
i care i care about all this [ __ ]
do you guys watch the show what was that
what's the show uh that [ __ ] everyone
wants you to watch now
that i say i'm oh it's the one uh
with the oh the the this is us
that's the i'm not watching it okay i
get that it's good
stop i'm not watching it dude i bet it's
great
not watching it that's the show that
everyone can now
stop talking about to me if you see me
on the street
don't talk about this is us to me you
got it also shit's creek
i'm sure it's [ __ ] hilarious not
watching it
not gonna watch both of those shows i'm
gonna die not knowing about those shows
that's fine
oh no not shit's creek the [ __ ] one
on hbo with brian cox
the one from the guy who from [ __ ]
goddamn i never know what that and the
culkin kid
disingenuous or whatever the [ __ ] it's
called
succession dude it's such a bad name
dude
let me be on it um anyway
man uh oh i [ __ ] like to be in
succession
um so yeah so that's it dude
i think i'll go back i think i'll go i
think i [ __ ] may all enroll in
college
start a new career as an inventor dude
[ __ ] that i'm an inventor
now imagine the balls you gotta have to
be like i'm an inventor
i guess you could say that if you're
elon musk but what about like the
non-famous inventors you gotta say that
[ __ ] that's gotta be
you know that's gonna be like [ __ ] a
girl saying she's a model when he's like
oh yeah okay great you're hot
the guy and it's just a tweed jacket and
what do you do oh i'm an inventor
what the [ __ ] did you invent and then
they got to explain it way too much
because it's like
you know those things that are on the
side of a thing and then you can and
they
you ever have the problem where you you
walk in and then and then the thing and
it gets caught
why invent the thing that is not a thing
so when you put it on there it doesn't
get caught
right that's what i do yeah yeah it's
patent pending but yeah um
or they say some a bright light i
invented the bright light you're like
what the [ __ ] is that
um and uh i'm gonna be yeah the balls
you gotta
i'm gonna i'm an inventor now [ __ ] it
but uh
yeah i'm gonna go back to dude i
remember when i did go to when i went to
college god this is so funny man i i
when i went to college my dad this is
how sentimental my dad is and this is
how [ __ ] by the way sentimental i am
now
i realize i see myself in my i see my
dad in me
because i now i have a kid
i see my my dad and how he looked at me
i
feel myself looking at calvin and my dad
sent me to college at nyu and i remember
the day that i
he said bye to me and walked away
he was wearing a shirt that i loved
of his it was a brown flannel shirt and
he said he gave me a hug and he said i
love you
uh have a good time and he went to walk
away
but then he took off the shirt and he
put it around my shoulders and he patted
me on the back and he said
it's yours now and
he said now i can say i really did give
you the shirt off my back
and he walked away and i said ah dad
thanks
and he crossed the street and i could
see him wiping his eyes you know
because he was crying because his kid
was going away to college
and he was so sentimental
and i get that now because i have a kid
and i could imagine that happening to
calvin when he grows up i would be
a wreck but back then i had no kid and
all i was thinking was isn't dad
cold like the difference between
that moment in my life and how i would
view it now is amazing
and the only thing that's different
about it that makes me feel that way
is the fact that i [ __ ] have made
this person and that's amazing
i can't wait to give them my they
wouldn't fit but
i'll give them the whole [ __ ] thing i
take the shirt the pants everything
shoes here take them all and i just run
[ __ ] through new york city with just
boxers on
um have a good time in college
isn't that that guy that used to be a
comedian
yeah that's my dad wink mink
yeah yeah that's my dad wait hold on
for [ __ ] sake god damn it i hate when
i [ __ ]
yeah hey isn't that it's like the
[ __ ] worst tv show of all time
hey isn't that my hey who's that naked
guy running across the [ __ ]
times square yeah that's my dad
previously on crazy dad
oh [ __ ] dude all right guys that's it
for the episode on youtube if you want
the full
extended uncut version you go over to my
patreon which is patreon.comcrystalia
see you there
[Music]
congratulations
you